[Música]
momento de nuestra revista de prensa con
Marta Moya Marta Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela vamos a comenzar esta
parte del programa con un artículo del
financial Times que publicó un texto en
el que se desgranan estas complicadas
relaciones que existen entre el gobierno
de bachar al azar y la ONU unas
relaciones que incluyen la contratación
de un familiar del jefe de la
inteligencia Siria por parte de Naciones
Unidas si Ángela nos referimos a la hija
de hashman lowca que es el jefe de la
dirección de inteligencia Siria que a su
vez ha sido sancionado por Estados
Unidos Reino Unido o la Unión Europea la
hija de este jefe de la inteligencia fue
contratada por la cerv que es una de
estas ayudas de fondos de emergencia
adscritos a la ONU que responden
rápidamente ante emergencias de
catástrofes naturales o conflictos
armados el medio el financial Times no
ha dado el nombre de la chica porque no
está imputada con ningún delito pero sí
que se sabe tiene más o menos unos 20
años y que antes ya había trabajado en
el comité Internacional de la Cruz Roja
y esto evidentemente muestra una vez más
esas controvertidas relaciones entre
Siria y el gobierno de bachar alasat con
las Naciones Unidas no destaca este
artículo que ya en 2016 se filtraron
unos documentos por los que la ONU ya
había contratado a familiares de altos
funcionarios del régimen de bachar
alássad se destaca una cita de uno de
estos trabajadores humanitarios que dice
no puedo decirles la cantidad de veces
que un funcionario del gobierno sirio
entró en nuestras oficinas y nos
presionó para que contratáramos a su
hijo las agencias de ayuda internacional
también han llegado a acuerdos incómodos
con el gobierno de bachar a lassad por
ejemplo desde 2014 la ONU ha pagado más
de 80 millones de dólares para alojarse
alojar a su equipo en un lujoso hotel en
Damasco que está a propiedad un
empresario que también está sancionado
por Estados Unidos no Y también todo
ello porque el gobierno no cede y no
ofrece alojamientos alternativos no esto
es bueno pues otro reflejo más de como
el gobierno de bachar a Last quiere
tener en corto a estas organizaciones
internacionales desde el inicio de la
guerra civil Siria en 2011 las agencias
han tenido que ceder no o bien transigen
Y ceden ante las presiones de bashara o
bien no pueden pues estar presentes en
el terreno y continuar con ese flujo de
ayuda humanitaria incluso deben aliarse
con las agencias de ayuda locales que
marcan un poco la Pauta no según
informes del centro de estudios
estratégicos y de Human right watch el
régimen restringe a estas organizaciones
pasar por algunas zonas destina la ayuda
a otras regiones preferenciales para
bajar a la SAT y además Bueno acosa al
personal de las ong completamente
viciado el proceso vamos a cambiar de
tema vamos a Estados Unidos este jueves
Washington post hace una recopilación de
algunos de los momentos más tensos de
las últimas semanas entre dos viejos
aliados el expresidente Donald Trump y
la cadena Fox news si esto de Bueno es
un tema que ha tenido bastante
relevancia en las últimas semanas ha
subido bastante de tono después de que
una empresa de conteo electrónico
denunciar a la Fox news por difamación y
le piden 1600 millones de dólares por
alentar esos Fantasmas del fraude
electoral que entonces elevaba al
expresidente Donald Trump No salieron
miles de mails y de mensajes de altos
directivos de la cadena más vista de
Estados Unidos en los que sabía cómo los
presentadores y otros productores decían
una cosa en privado que no había fraude
y en público decían bueno alentaban esos
fantasmas no Entonces desde entonces y
según recoge este artículo del
Washington post hay una suerte de guerra
tácita entre el expresidente y su
campaña y la cadena estadounidense Fox
news no los asesores de Donald Trump al
final ven en Fox news un adversario en
esa carrera presidencial de 2024 a la
que se quiere presentar Donald Trump
además han buscado pues aumentar desde
la campaña de esa división entre los
altos mandos de la Fox news entre Los
Patriotas y valientes y los traidores
que le han dejado de lado Trump por
ejemplo acusó al presidente ejecutivo de
la Fox news de instigar la caída de
Estados Unidos y además de doblegarse
ante los demócratas en los últimos meses
y semanas Pues ya ni la nuera de Donald
Trump participan las tertulias Donald
Trump ya no entra por teléfono y el hijo
también ha denunciado que los últimos
seis meses no le han dado cabida no Esto
bueno la Fox además ha dado más
relevancia en los últimos días y semanas
al candidato opositor de del partido
republicano ron de santis veremos más
episodios de esto pero vamos a terminar
rápidamente en Israel un columnista
Disculpe del currier Internacional hace
un análisis de posibles escenarios Al
Calor de las tensiones sociales por la
tributaria de neta Yahoo sí Y este es un
de Hansel que dibuja seis posibles
escenarios sobre todo en vísperas de la
Pascua judía no que empieza el 5 de
abril y viendo un poco Cómo están la
situación ahora mismo en Israel el
primer escenario que dibuja Es que la
mayoría de derecha consiga finalmente
pasar la reforma tributaria la reforma
judicial sí
la reforma judicial perdón el segundo
escenario es que el presidente isaker
shock al final logre reunir a todos los
agentes políticos que estas un escenario
bastante improbable el tercer escenario
es que Washington y el mundo económico
presionen y al final netan Yahoo ponga
en pausa esta reforma judicial e intente
ganar tiempo el cuarto escenario Es que
la Corte Suprema declare una reforma
judicial que impida las prerrogativas
contra las leyes básicas y además
impidan etangyahu ejercer como Primer
Ministro por el caso de corrupción que
tiene a sus espaldas El quinto escenario
contempla la fuga de empresas y la
depreciación de la moneda y la caída de
la bolsa de tel aviv que esto Bueno pues
motivaría a netanyahua suspender de
manera definitiva la reforma y por
último el sexto escenario es que
alentados por los ministros de extrema
derecha al final los colonos extremistas
aumenten la violencia en la cisjordania
ocupada y en los territorios palestinos
Ángela pues Marta gracias a usted por la
sección y nos vemos mañana nos vemos
mañana Gracias